we're here at blizzcon 2016 I'm Justin
and this is eric in sombra earlier today
invaded the blizzcon kino and reveals
herself as the new character we knew she
was coming for a long time but we also
got a chance to player to try around she
has a lot of interesting new abilities
yeah I mean she is a kind of what we
predicted on the lobby kind of a
infiltrator a skirmisher I mean funny
enough the trailer was called
infiltration I think she gets up in your
face with the SMG it's pretty stable
it's you know like what do you think it
would be it's only really good like kind
of short to medium-range it felt like
long range you're kind of just like
pecking them a little bit so what really
separates ombre I feel like from some of
the other characters she has her hack
ability which not only works on enemy
opponents but it also works on turrets
as well as health packs health packs are
interesting in the sense that you can
deny health packs from the other team as
well as speed up the frequency of health
packs for your actual team she isn't a
soul class but these kind of abilities
almost make her feel like she's support
in some ways because the ability to hack
your opponent's can be a huge game
changer but in the midst of a really
heated battle speaking of getting into
the action the translocator not only get
lets her get into action but also away
from action so you basically throw down
this little mine or so to speak that
allows you to teleport to it within 15
seconds you can either throw that behind
you like your health pack so that you
can safely get back there or you can
throw it in front of you to try to like
close the gap on someone or get in front
of the enemy opponents so that you might
potentially use our ultimate or things
like that it's kind of similar to
tracers ability but that time limit
definitely makes it feel like you have a
you have to use it very carefully and so
once you're out of that danger that her
other ability to avoid danger is just
turning invisible which it's completely
invisible the opponent cannot see you at
all which is really interesting yeah and
on top of just the invisibility you gain
movement speed it's relatively quick
it's her kind of movement mechanic in
the game and it's very powerful because
it's going to allow you to do things
like sneak up on an enemy team maybe
illusio drops the beat guess what she
can use her EMP which is their ultimate
ability to cancel that out and then hack
all of the opponent
near her which can then lead to huge
wombo combo you know Farah Ultimates
Reinhard slams you name it the ult
definitely puts her into the category of
a character who's going to be difficult
to use really well but once you know how
to use her will be devastating to
another team like I'm really excited for
her as an assault class it's gonna be
hard to learn but really fun what you've
mastered it well for us we were playing
6v6 sombra and when she comes out on PTR
it probably going to be a lot more of 6
p-6 ambra so you really have to see it
in a real-world setting to see how her
ult is gonna impact a real match yeah I
mean super fun character from the
limited time that I got to play just
more diversity I feel like kind of like
a hybrid character kind of something
like what Mike wanted something that you
know she does she is offensive but she
can also help her team out in a way like
almost pseudo support by hacking health
packs and denying health packs so yeah
yeah so sombra is available for the
first time here at blizzcon and will be
coming in public test realm is really
soon and let us know what you think
about it when you get to try it out in
the comments below
you